welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and did Wilson Fisk Kingpin by
Avengers Tower let's look deeper into
the post credit scene for the echo
series and what Marvel Studios
Executives have promised about the
Avengers Tower mystery to see what
Wilson fisk's next moves will be for
Daredevil born again for Thunderbolts
Captain America Brave New World and
everything on the street level of the
MCU in Phase 5 is Wilson fisk's upcoming
Mayoral race really setting the stage
for a White House bid God help us hey by
the way all five episodes of Ekko were
broken down with amazing attention to
detail by Jessica Clemens on this new
Rockstar Channel be sure to give those a
watch okay the echo series ends with
Wilson Fisk being defeated in his fight
with Maya Lopez in the town of tamaha
Oklahoma as Maya accessed the power of
her Chaka ancestry and shared it with
other women in her family her
grandmother Chula and her cousin Bonnie
and Maya used this specific gesture it
seems to begin to heal some of the
trauma in fisk's heart from his
childhood bedroom as he would listen to
his father abusing his mother this post
credit scene shows FIS back on his
private jet headed back to New York I
want a meeting with with all the
remaining
heads we need to stabilize this
situation before it spirals out of
control okay before we continue with the
rest of the scene we got to talk about
these remaining heads in the Netflix
dared series which Marvel executive Brad
wibom recently confirmed to bmcu Canon
Fisk dealt with the other heads of New
York City specifically Hell's Kitchen
including Madame Gaal noou Leland dowley
and the Russian Brothers Vladimir and
anatol rahav depending on how committed
Marvel Studios will be to the exact
continuity of the Netflix series all of
those heads have either been dead or out
of the picture for the past several
years and notice how Fisk says the
remaining heads suggesting that some
have either been arrested or killed or
just removed from power in the recent
era like Wilson Fisk may have just like
killed off anyone who wasn't loyal
enough to him now we should be clear on
the timeline here Ekko is set 5 months
later following the events of the
Hawkeye series the Hawkeye series was
Christmas 2024 so now we are in May
20125 and according to Disney Plus's
timeline order playlist which by the way
now includes the Marvel Netflix titles
of Daredevil Jessica Jones Luke K iron V
Defenders and Punisher Echo takes place
before She-Hulk and before Miss Marvel
so I'm going to assume that the heads
that Fisk is now referring to are
actually a shadowy cabal senior to any
New York specific gangs I think Fisk is
thinking on a more National and
international level so who would these
MCU heads of crime currently be of
course we got to consider power broker
Sharon Carter magore got named dropped
in this Echo series but that's all stuff
from mad repor and Sharon ended the
Falcon the Winter Soldier making a
similar Call to Arms dealers to kind of
circle the wagons we also got to think
about Xing current head of the 10 Rings
Syndicate there's Val Val is the current
CIA director which is a you know
government position but she's clearly
not operating in the daylight she's
cutting legal Corners with John Walker's
legal status the fact that Val is
director of the CIA is just a sign of
how corrupt the US government currently
is in the MCU and we got to look at
Samuel Sterns the leader because Tim
Blake Nelson is confirmed to return as
the Hulk villain in next year's Captain
America Brave New World so those four
with Wilson Fisk overseeing the Russian
gangs in New York from Hawkeye would
bring us to five heads and I think this
could be the mcu's intelligencia and yes
I know the intelligencia was kind of
implied to be a group based out of a
silly incel website in She-Hulk and that
group of immature dudes seems to have a
bit of doubtful canonicity since Jen
Walters and the Kevin robot retconed
that from the end of She-Hulk but I
think there was still a real
intelligencia that was using that
website as a front so that people
wouldn't look deeper into it because
remember we saw a Hightech lab that was
spying on Jen Walters in that She-Hulk
wedding episode so where was that lab
who was that could that lab be Avengers
Tower in the days before ekko's release
our friend Brandon Davis from
comicbook.com interviewed Marvel exec
Brad WBAL who confirmed that we will at
some point learn who bought Avengers
Tower mention New York I got a question
I've been dying to have answered for
like I think seven years now am I ever
going to know who bought Avengers
Tower uh
Brandon I'm just going honestly yes yes
you will now this Echo series did not
answer that question but W bomb didn't
say that it would get answered an echo
specifically it was just at some point
and when Maya snuck a bomb aboard the
Fisk train and bombed fisk's Brooklyn
Warehouse the shots of the New York City
skyline did not as usual include any
sign of Avengers Tower specifically in
the part of Midtown Manhattan's metti
building where the tower is supposed to
be located now in Jessica's breakdown
she theorized that this's eyepiece Tech
could be a mix of Tony Stark's Edith
technology and that skin grafting cradle
technology that show used an Avengers
Tower in Age of Ultron and she pointed
to these as possible clues that Wilson
fist could be the one currently
occupying the tower but we should also
note that those things seem to be the
kind of proprietary technology that
happy Hogan would have been sure to move
out of the tower in Spider-Man
homecoming but then again as of
Spider-Man no way home a lot of that
Tech was seized by the government
through the dodc a government whose
intelligence apparatus is being overseen
by Val and in Miss Marvel which again is
set after Echo the dodc is using Tony
Stark's drones drones that they must
have confiscated and repurposed so if
Val is using her government contacts to
do all of this that could put her in the
league of Avengers Tower occupants and
one of fisk's heads but is Fisk about to
take all of this public if you're
looking to ring in the New Year by
ringing in a new you revamping your
daily hygiene routine is the best place
to start and geology is here to help
your New Year's resolutions with new
skinc Care Solutions geology is a 29
time award-winning skin hair and body
care company recognized in men's health
opra daily hype Beast birdie Esquire and
GQ G's products used just like a handful
of powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
I mean is it really a new year if you
don't age I don't think so if you don't
know where to start geology can create a
simple and effective skincare or hair
care routine for you all you got to do
is take a quick 30second quiz right now
if you use code new rockstars 100
geology will give you 100% off their
award- winning skincare trial set you'll
also get an additional bonus offer of up
to 30% off one skin hair or body product
when you add it to your trial so 100%
off plus an additional 30% off hope you
save some champagne because this is a
deal worth celebrating click the link in
the description or go to G log. i/
Rockstar 100 to get started because
let's continue with this Echo post
credit scene most voters want somebody
who is a fighter which works against the
career politicians a bare knuckled braw
would do well in this race an outsider
is that candidate even out there yeah
sounds like Wilson FIS is following in
the footsteps of another mayor Wilson
mayor now that's a good idea I could run
for mayor so Wilson Fisk running for
mayor is an expected move in Marvel lore
in season one of the Netflix series he
steps Out of the Shadows with a
televised pledge to improve H Kitchen in
the devil's rain Comics FK is the mayor
of New York City and outlaws vigilantism
and announces a run for president and
forms Thunderbolts units to enforce that
agenda in the secret Empire Comics Fisk
steps in as a last minute meril
candidate after helping throw off
hydra's takeover of the city so I think
we are going to see a similar campaign
by Wilson Fisk and Daredevil born again
and this whole idea of Marvel looking
into like us electoral politics it's
something that we saw a bit of in secret
Invasion and I think we're going to see
a lot more in Thunderbolts in Captain
America Brave New World Brave New World
is going to deal with President thadius
Ross played by Harrison Ford with
perhaps some Red Hulk drama that could
create a power void in Washington and
mayor Wilson from New York could enter
that ring and then from there Outlaw all
superhero actions except those committed
by his Thunderbolts lineup the lineup
that will be in this movie that he and
Val control so who bought Avengers Tower
not any one person I don't think but
rather an organization a team with
multiple heads wait a minute Hydra has
multiple heads no I I don't think it's
Hydra I guess it could be but I don't
know I mean there was that episode of
what if that suggested that arnam Zola's
AI was still in that Siberian facility
in some form but the Forefront of this
organization includes someone with US
Government backing that would be Val
someone with a solid stake in Manhattan
real estate wison Fisk someone with
armored Firepower in a ton of money that
would be the power broker of magore
Sharon Carter someone with International
reach that would be the head of the tin
Rings Xing someone with technological
Savvy and the ability to spread
misinformation that would be Samuel
Sterns the leader and there you go
Avengers Tower I believe is the current
base of operations of the true
intelligencia now K Sasha Baron Cohen
misto be part of That League to validate
these weird rumors being claimed by some
scoopers at misto bought Avengers Tower
sure why not throw him in there either
way I don't think Avengers Tower was
bought by one person I think it's been
bought by several working together and I
know that might disappoint some of you
who firmly believe that Avengers Tower
is the current based of operations of
ocor or the backer building but hold
your horses none of this is saying the
tower can't in the future be reclaimed
By the Fantastic boards the backer
building on the other side of all these
conflicts in a Fantastic Four film I
just think that for that least transfer
to have any meaning to us to pack the
greatest punch we need to see that Tower
in the wrong hands first we need to see
Minas tyth in denior hands before the
true Arab Gondor returns to take it by
the way I'm still working on my Lord of
the Rings analysis for the Deep dive
channel it's just you know having a kid
it makes it hard to pour through a three
and a half hour extended edition but I
am working on it I promise hey please
watch all of Jessica's Echo breakdowns
and Tommy Beck told and I teamed up on
Sunday's sneak peek episode and we went
pretty hard against Marvel Studios for
burying the series in our opinion and
then meanwhile this Channel's X-Men
stick stick rewatch is charging forth
with 2003's X2 Xmen United that is on
the channel now for you to watch and to
enjoy subscribe to all three channels of
the new rockstars Network you can follow
me at eaos thank you to Gina AO for her
help with this script thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
bye